[Music]
welcome to this week's fall for Thursday
we're gonna be talking this week about
what are the risks when buying for my
property saucer and how can you protect
yourself to make sure that nothing goes
wrong so I'm here with Alastair hey
great over the show Billy thanks so
obviously you know you've been a
property sorcerer yeah you know the
industry really really well which is
great just to set a little bit of
context there's been quite a lot of talk
in the property investors world recently
about a particular sorcerer who's been
taking people's money not supplying what
he's supposed to be supplying it's
caused quite a lot of controversy yeah I
personally know quite a few people the
lost money you know and bought deals
where they've basically didn't haven't
me deals that existed and all those
things so do you first of all just we
give it a little bit context you know
more about it than I do so what's the
sort of contest what's happened to
people okay so I'm not going to talk
about one particular source I'm just
going to talk about in general yeah
what's been happening is people have
been given money to source us yeah and
the property deals are don't exist
they've been on the wrong contracts
they've been in the wrong names they've
been all sorts so there's this when
you're buying off sources you need to
make sure there's lots there's due
diligence you have to do you need to
make sure that you're buying from
somebody reputable now for instance I
would say the first if I could give
advice on what to look for words that
work well yeah first of all clarify the
problem animes there's a lot of sources
numbers don't stack up a lot of sources
are not using the crepe paper well see
that quite a lot though when they put
the ROI in and they don't include things
like fame they're eight grand
yeah if you're not going to include the
costs yeah really a return on investment
a lot of people are just not stacking
the deal was properly that they don't
understand how to do the due diligence
and they don't understand what figures
to include what figures not to include
yeah if you buy a property from better
source limited whenever we see an ROI
that includes a refined
Fiza includes all the fees you're
possibly gonna have to pay
obviously there might be exceptions
where things are a little bit higher
it's not it's not an exact science but
it's it's it's it to give you I think
the first thing probably then is that
you need to understand yourself how to
work out a return on investment you make
sure the walls that we pulled over your
eyes yeah 100% and don't please please
please do not think just could you're
buying from a property sorcerer that the
deal is 100% guaranteed cast-iron solid
it's not yeah all it means is that
they've they've gone out and done the
legwork they've looked at probably 10 20
houses to find one and they've done the
due diligence as best of their ability
the with the the figures that they can
get hold of in the figures they've got
and they've they put that in a they
presented that to you in a manner that
you can look at all in one in in one
eight one sort of inch or one page and
so you basically you're not having to go
out and look at ten properties and look
at ten sets of figures and ten sets of
this is there is there a point though if
you've got to be checking all the work
they've done you've got to be doing your
due diligence not on the house it's
early but on them as well that's what
we're you might think why not obviously
you're a sorcerer but is there a point
where you might think isn't it just as
easy to go and find a deal as it is they
mind a good deal also yes and I'm all
for that but what I will say is if you
find a good source or and a good
packager that you can get on within you
trust then you don't have to at once
it's like getting in because agent I'll
tell you something and most of my
businesses for repeat business mmm it's
not newbies coming along so you know I
want to put my hand up by its repeat
business I've got investors that have
bought multiples seven eight nine houses
of me and the reason they come back to
me is because we're doing a good job
we're not trying to pull the wool over
enemy's eyes we're not trying to rip
anybody off if a deal falls through we
have refund procedures in place we have
a refund policy for instance well that's
okay isn't it of course it is it's legal
it's a legal requirement this whole new
refund policy is illegal you have to
have a refund policy there's no two ways
about it but what I will say it doesn't
matter what business you're in if you're
an unethical businessman
you want to be unethical in whatever
business you're in whether that be I
don't know well it'd be vehicles will
that be supplying products for a home
well doesn't matter do you think there
are a lot of the time as well if you've
got a source come it's been around for a
while yeah
chances are because of the product
you're not going to be able to continue
ripping people off no I'm getting you a
weaver to do it once you'll do it why
build it so you're gonna build a
business doing that oh yeah you might
get away for three months six months at
some point yeah the the the poo is gonna
hit the fan of course it is but what
will say look if you're if you're
looking to use a saucer hmm you got to
look at the people or the business that
you're working with yeah look at their
website does the website tell you
everything you need to know about them
does it have their details on there yeah
their contact details their phone
numbers their addresses their VAT num
what would you say we should be checking
then so VAT number hold on let me tell
you go on the website on the website you
check for their company name yep check
for their address yeah check for their
complaints procedure yeah check for the
property redress scheme number yeah
their insurance policies you want to be
checked about that website is their face
of their business so make sure that the
website gives you all the information
you need to know about that business so
if you've got a problem it's not some
one-page website it's been knocked up on
five our that has no information on
there are no details on there now just
be aware that by law if you have a
website you have to have your company
name on there you have to have contact
information online you have to have that
numbers on no bylaw it's not it's not
maybe it is by law okay now to be a
compliance or so you're happy member of
the property redress scheme again on all
your documentation you have to have your
property redress it's kinda just
explains often it doesn't know how does
that protect okay so if you've got
problem mm-hmm
obviously see you see you buy property
and as an issue yeah the first port of
call will always be who you bought the
problem the property through that's your
contractors with them so your first
protocol will be to contact them through
their complaints Becerra buy property of
you yeah right and it sucks
yep right a just wasn't what you told me
was gonna be okay so I then come to you
and I say hey
this property is not what you said these
are the actual figures I'm really fed up
about it all right obviously I should
check that as well myself is the first
thing I need to do is check though I
think it's a good deal you well I'm sure
that what would give me a refund right
but let's see it all depends it depends
on a lot of things yeah but let's say I
went to a different source and they're
like sorry not interested sold a scene
map right but they remember the of the
property read your screen then yeah you
I do you can't bring up with a property
redress scheme
yeah and I'm providing you for the
correct complaints procedure then they
will look into it what I found from from
experience is that they tend to side
with the the buyer okay which is from a
buyer's point of view I'm watching this
it's good I've never had that experience
I've not had any I've never liked um
I've never had complaints about a
complaint but we deal with it in an
effective manner I've never personally
dealt with it just from what I've been
told yes that when people have said to
him and they've gone through the
probably rigid screams they they tended
to know to have it so don't know for
sure but that's all steps that are an
investor should take when look at the
battle my thoughts are firstly the
website needs to be complete it needs to
be you need to have as much information
in that website as possible so you know
where you're going you need to know that
there's continuation with everything
they're doing so what I mean by that is
for instance if on their website they
are properly sourcing limited whatever
hmm and then on the Facebook there are
properties are ass they're not linked
they're not the same they're usually
named when doing this research before
you even sign up for their database I
would recommend you're not getting
tempted by hundred percent and you need
to make sure this continuation there's
that there's a pattern that folds across
all of their social media of everything
they're using the same name check in to
the limited company do your due
diligence challenges are answers check
in to the directors are they convicted
fraudster are they have they been
convicted for x of the have the just
come out of prison have the I don't know
do your research
have they got a string of redundant
companies or have they got loads of
companies that gone bankrupt
mmm-hmm that have only been around for a
year or have they go
listen there's nothing wrong with having
a dissolve company was why was it
dissolved if they've got Lords of the
salt dissolved companies and me they
just wanna go you've got a bit to a
degree the suppose the other thing is as
well is testimonials yeah and are they
getting a real testimonial so via social
media and stuff are not just ones look
at that pot on their website are people
talking about them have people bought
deals for them what's the experience
been like of those people and you took
review for example a better source you
see loads of people talking about you
want on on social media on the group's
oh yeah but a property first aired it
was awesome this happened but I it's all
good good good good feedback so it to
check other people it's not they don't
have that one thing I'll say look
there's nothing wrong with charging an
upfront fee to people an upfront fee you
do i do hundred saying you don't get
propped off me unless you pick me up
people are from however there's a
difference between charge and an upfront
free and then and not looking after that
money right when we charge not from free
we take the fee and it goes into a
client account and it stays there until
our terms and conditions have expired
now if in that time period a customer
wants a refund because the deal doesn't
stack in their opinion or they've gone
out and they're not Hyundai get away
from they get a refund
I do not care about giving refunds what
Gary it's my goal or what really bugs me
is when you hear about these sources
that they're that will not give refunds
because the deals don't stack and
because the deals don't exist and I've
got friend it's just a loan and haul is
necessarily if it exists it's just
out-and-out fraud is fraud I've got
friends of mine who friends with from
within the Academy yeah that uh they
have bought properties from other
sources because they were looking for
specific types of deals then properties
have never uh never materialized and
they're not getting they won't they will
not be given refunds and they are
they're asking for refunds and they're
just not getting refunds to all sources
I think I think the key is is just to be
aware and the but be aware there's a
potential and just and just do your own
expect if you get to know the person if
you know where they're at if they're if
they're on life they another thing I
look for sorry
business I'm doing I'm hiring a cleaner
at the moment we just moved house I was
looking for a clean town and I've seen
that there's someone for it that lives
in the village that a lot of other
people use on Facebook and I thought I
can kind of trust that person because
they live in the village where we are
and they will care about their
reputation yeah one for when so I'd be
happy to let them have a key to my house
because I know who they are I don't know
I don't know but I know that she
socially has a reputation and and she
lives in it's only a very small village
she lives in the village now she's not
gonna wear a risk doing anything for her
reputation same with our business with
Samuel he's not gonna do anything that's
at this out of line because he's got a
reputation so if you can find a sorcerer
like yourself or someone's got a
reputation that they care about yeah
it's gonna make it and do you know what
ultimately I think it comes down to the
person hmm if you're a good person
doesn't matter what you're doing you'll
do it is best to your ability mmm if
you're a corn man if you're a scam
artist doesn't know what business you
and you're gonna scam people yeah again
it comes down to the person if you trust
that person do business one if you've
got this even this smallest doubt do not
do business with them yeah do not simple
end off there's no discussion about it
because then if you do do business with
these people then you've got your you've
only got yourself to blame yeah that's
true so check the company number one
hundred percent make that number but
make sure the fact number exists I know
another source oh he was charging back
shouldn't be charge him about not about
registered that's not only fraud that's
that's criminal you can go to prison for
that he was charging that he is not that
registered I know someone who does it as
well we're probably talking at the same
Paris over but yeah it is disgraceful
and criminal so check all these figures
check their insurance policies up to
date and it's valid on my website I have
a page all about compliance I put my
policy numbers on there so you can ring
up and I give anyone permission like my
insurance brokers got permission they
have in all rings up and says is this
company registered with you they've got
permission to discuss my insurance with
you and PRS PRS check online checked
even EOBRs sister auntie sorry t-bo
give you all the PRS is to the property
redress system auu PRS I'm the property
Ombudsman your TP oh so you can be one
of one of one of our that doesn't matter
let's take on the systems to me actually
they're registered check the
registration is in the name of the
person that owns the company mm-hmm
again that's I see this all the time
where people have a PRS license for
another company but they sell through
this company this company is not
registered this company may be but
you're not mine of this company you're
buying off this company so this company
has you only do this once yeah question
and then you found a source that you're
happy with it and like I said I've
bought from sources buy from sources is
good it saves a lot of time there's a
lot of viewing lot of efforts and I'm a
source of I will buy off the saucer
yeah I will yeah I'd write bill if the
right deal comes along I'll buy officers
I'd bought of you of course you have
yeah yeah
what picking up money of you so I hope
you guys find that pretty helpful so
just to you there are a lot of not a lot
but there are some people that are that
are prepared to that are calm man and
stuff so just it's just you know a lot
of people took - at the moment so
there's a lot there's a lot terrified
what it is the e to looking for because
I want to say I don't want to see anyone
getting burned also don't are all
sources with the same brush because
there's a lot of good guys out there are
there is there it's just it's anything
it's the same with the racist ranting at
the football it's a couple of people
that ruin it for everybody else
but yeah so I hope you found that useful
and don't forget to tune in next
Thursday for another
[Music]